[Music]
hey rick you're following what's
happening in thailand
some kids stuck in a cove
[Music]
we're on the list of rescue divers
it's just a tourist cave it looks easy
but when it's flooded it's impossible
takes a certain kind of mindset for the
deep cave diving you have to be a bit
nuts
they're very very dangerous
high water level and a low visibility
barely shoulder-wide pulling against
last seen nine days ago twelve boys and
their coach are trapped in the flooded
caves
hello
hey
they're here
how many of you 13
13. they're all alone
can we
go out now
you try and drive those kids the whole
way or you'll be bringing out is dead
bodies
with oxygen running low the entire
nation is anxiously waiting for what
will happen next
what are you thinking
just a crazy idea but a skill none of
the rest of us have
no
it's insane it's unethical it's illegal
man's already died
but do nothing we'll be bringing them
out there for sure
so you are expecting casualties
yes
i expect casualties
[Music]
johnny okay yeah i'm okay just give me a
minute
okay
we can make it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you